he said
supporters were quite distressed and
disappointed by recent events and he
shared their feelings he said we cannot
carry on as business as usual and
someone should take responsibility and
then he said volunteers and staffers
deserve better than this i know you've
dismissed suggestions you'd resign as
crazy you intend to carry on anyone the
confidence vote but i imagine some
colleagues back in london might be
pretty astonished watching this
press conference
given that you've been asked repeatedly
and you don't seem to acknowledge
that you
could be
part of the problem you and your conduct
could be part of the problem uh with
voters why won't you acknowledge that i
mean you're safe you've won the
conference vote can you not just let me
try to give you give you give you the
best stance right now which is that
first of all on oliver uh i think he uh
did a lot of uh good work particularly
uh as chairman but it also is as
secretive state for a dcms on broadband
rollout uh on uh veterans affairs and
and other things i thank him for uh for
his service but i
genuinely genuinely don't think uh the
way forward in british politics is uh to
focus on issues of personalities whether
they are mine or others the way forward
is to make arguments to people about
change and improvement that we are
delivering and that is what i want to do
i think that the government has got some
difficult stuff right people are now
going through a tough time we understand
that i think that we have the the best
way forward i think that we understand
how to fix our economic issues how to
make sure that we have a stronger
economy and that is what we're going to
achieve i think some signs are uh are
promising but you know i've got to be
i've got to be clear with people as i
was during the the pandemic i think um
it will take some time and there will
still be some some
some tough times ahead and no doubt uh
beth people will you know will continue
to to beat me up and and say this all
that about you know
to attack me that's fine that's quite
right that is the job of politicians
in the end uh voters journalists they
have no one else
uh to make their complaints to i have to
i have to take that but i also have to
get on uh with the job of delivering for
the for the people of this country and
that's what i was elected uh to do